these verses have been highly taken out
of
uh
perspective i think okay
on people's first maybe second order
there's a little misunderstanding about
the meaning yes okay yeah so
i'm writing about
a guy that's
in a relationship where the his partner
starts to feel like maybe they're
cheating on them
and i'm writing this from the
perspective of someone who's like yo
everything you everything that attracted
you to me
has now turned into your insecurities
right that happens a lot happens a lot
guys and girls yeah right
so it's like you you liked me for
for who i was for being fly for being a
good looking dude for being you know
funny cool whatever all these things but
now because as soon as i leave the crib
it's an issue yeah you want me to yeah
you dressed up exactly exactly why you
got a brand new shirt on where are you
going where are you going you know oh
you're going over there oh you're going
to oh you're going to be talking and all
these
these hoes faces you got to be the life
of the party like it's like you met me
this way you liked me because of these
things you always liked being around my
energy all these things like that and
now it's turned into this now you're
digging through phones and you know
checking instagram followers and
all that stuff like that so that's the
perspective that i'm writing about it so
people hear me say i'm a fly [ __ ] when
you got here charismatic when you got
here and they're thinking oh he's
telling the girls like he was fly you
should already know i'm gonna be [ __ ]
these hoes or something whatever but
it's like that's not what i was saying i
was saying i was these things and now
well that's also a very important thing
to convey because a lot of people feel
that way what that i was flying i was
already [ __ ] these hoes no that oh
when you get into a relationship like
you said it always happens whether it's
the guy or the girl yeah
when you think about it a lot of dudes
will meet a chick in the club who's
[ __ ] beautiful [ __ ] ass out
whatever and it's like well that's how
you met this girl that's what attracted
you to her exactly now that you cuffed
her like you can't get mad she's going
out with her home girls exactly so
that's that's the perspective i wrote
the verses from and then i was like it
gets into the the idea of
okay so now you're now you're doing the
digging through the phone [ __ ]
are you trying to find a problem or are
you trying to find an actual reason to
leave
and then comes the
because and why would why would you want
to leave when even if hypothetically i
was to cheat on you it wouldn't be
because all of a sudden i just lost my
feelings for you and i i don't love you
anymore right it would be probably
because i just did something super
selfish super self-indulgent
super you know me being addicted to
being [ __ ] short-sighted you know
stroking my ego all these other things
and i think that's the mis a big
misconception with people about why
people cheat and that's what we wanted
to bring to the table it's usually not
about the other person especially with
guys sometimes sometimes you hear women
say you know that you know they only did
it because there was a lack of something
or a void right emotional disconnect
whatever it is they were getting
something in their relationship they
went to go find it but guys especially a
lot of guys i know girls too but a lot
of guys commonly we can hear that yo
they have the girl they want right
this just literally had nothing to do
with them